alors excusez moi mais j'ai juste pas
très bien compris ce que vous me
demandiez par téléphone notre amie
julie va bientôt nous quitter et nous on
aimerait lui offrir cette dernière
histoire d'amour les peintures des
gaulnes clairement comme ça pourtant
c'est une mauvaise imitation de denis
robert
de niro sessad aignan qui tu parles pas
de mort tu parles pas de vie qui à la
vie à la mort elle et qui tous les
bizuths a faim et avec fils vianney dit
viens de faire
du mal à me viens moi-même
vous êtes venus seuls sur ce bateau
oui pourquoi pas parce qu'en général
quand on vient seul sait que c'est qu'il
ya un problème m'a donc vous aussi vous
avez un problème et alors vous êtes dit
je vais aller me consoler avec le
premier venu sais pas si le premier venu
n'est pas le dernier décompte pourquoi
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
on pensait que l'amour ces mecs-là vie
maintenant oui
[Musique]